Good morning John, it's Wednesday, July 18th.
I'm going to have to wait until Friday to do the green hair thing because today's Wednesday, it's my Wednesday
and so I must do a song. This a pretty long song and I have to fit it all in. It's about Harry Potter.
♫ I'm getting kinda tired of this pre-publication media blitz. You've got all of mugglekind under your spell. ♫
♫ Don't you know the whole world's already gone and reserved a copy at Amazon? ♫
♫ How many more books could you sell? ♫
♫ Now give me my book or go to Hell! ♫
♫ Because I need Harry Potter, like a grindylow needs water. ♫
♫ And as Saturday approaches my need grows. ♫
♫ Oh, accio Deathly Hallows, incendio book sales embargos ♫
♫ it'll be like phoenix tears on a broken nose. ♫
♫ Yeah, accio Deathly Hallows. Accio Deathly Hallows. ♫
♫ I'm gettin' kinda petrified. What would Ron do if Hermione died? ♫
♫ Or if Voldemort killed Hedwig just for yucks? ♫
♫ I have no confidence in theories about the Half-Blood Prince ♫
♫ and what if Harry's brain is a horcrux? ♫
♫ Oh, holy crap! That would freakin' suck. ♫
♫ 'Cuz, I need Harry Potter, like a grindylow needs water. ♫
♫ And as Saturday approaches my need grows. ♫
♫ Accio Deathly Hallows, incendio book sales embargos. ♫
♫ It'll be like phoenix tears on a broken nose. ♫
♫ Woah, accio Deathly Hallows.  ♫
♫ Whatever's up the sleeves of JK Rowling I bet it has to do with Snape unbreakably vowing to protect that pure-blood puss face Malfoy.  ♫
♫ But in the end, I don't think it's gonna matter if Snape is good or if he's bad because the weight of the world rests on our boy. ♫
♫ Yeah, the weight of the world rests on our boy. ♫
♫ 'Cuz, we need Harry Potter, like a grindylow needs water. ♫
♫ And as that day approaches our need grows. ♫
♫ Oh accio Deathly Hallows, incendio book sales embargos. ♫
♫ It'll be like phoenix tears on a broken nose. ♫
♫ Yeah, accio Deathly Hallows. Oh, accio Deathly Hallows. ♫
♫ But mostly I'm just feelin' sad. I know this could end real bad, but I wish it didn't have to end at all. ♫
♫ Yeah, I wish it didn't have to end at all! ♫
♫ 'Cuz I couldn't care more about Harry Potter if Hogwarts was my alma matter and as Saturday approaches my need grows. ♫
♫ Yeah, accio Deathly Hallows, incendio book sales embargos. ♫
♫ It'll feel like phoenix tears on a broken nose. ♫
♫ Yeah, accio Deathly Hallows. Oh, accio Deathly Hallows. ♫
♫ Accio Deathly Hallows. Accio Deathly Hallows. Oh, accio Deathly Hallows. ♫
♫ John, I'll see you tomorrow. ♫